these buses are carrying refugees from
the embattled city of kobani to a camp
in dohuk in northern iraq
the civil war in syria has made millions
of people homeless
resources are scarce the united nations
says the camps are only funded until
january
some three billion dollars are needed to
get the refugees through the winter
that's according to the un high
commissioner for refugees
germany's foreign minister has called
the syrian crisis the greatest
humanitarian challenge of our time
the reality on the ground is beyond
human imagination 12 million people who
have lost their homes are fighting for
their survival
half of them are children
the situation is indeed dramatic the
world food program was forced to
temporarily suspend food aid to 1.7
million syrians because it had run out
of money
germany's development minister gerd
muller announced a hundred million euros
in immediate aid but also called on
other european countries to step up
it's unacceptable that we have to ask
the international community month after
month to do their part
to prevent people from dying in their
refugee camps in jordan syria and iraq
the united nations wants europe to
commit to over eight and a half billion
dollars in aid to secure long-term
support for the syrian refugees and
their host countries
you